good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from Sierra Leone and the maternal
Center of Excellence so Hank this is the
48 000 square foot maternal and infant
care center currently being built in
Sierra Leone these are a few of the
women building it and this is my crying
and sweaty face as it sinks in how many
lives are being helped by our little
online community but let me back up
eight years ago when Partners in Health
began working with Sierra Leone's
Ministry of Health to strengthen the
Health Care system in the Kono District
the Maternity Ward at koidu government
hospital did not look like this
overflowing with new moms receiving
excellent care with a functioning
operating room and blood bank and
medical residents training to be the
next generation of Sierra leonean
Physicians no eight years ago it looked
like this dirt 4's devoid of patience
due to a long history of impoverishment
a horrific Civil War and the collapse of
the already fragile Health Care system
during the Ebola epidemic what's been
accomplished since is remarkable Kono
was the epicenter of the world's
maternal mortality crisis with one in 17
women dying in childbirth or pregnancy
but that's changed both maternal and
child mortality have declined
dramatically still the Health Care
system in Kono remains inadequate there
are only 41 maternal beds to serve a
population of over 500 000 people so the
Maternity Ward is perpetually over full
and mothers and children in Kono are
still dying every day for want of
emergency C-sections ambulance services
and drugs to combat postpartum
Hemorrhage it's simply not acceptable
and also we don't have to accept it
that's where the maternal Center of
Excellence comes in with help from the
nearly 40 million dollars raised by
nerdfighteria and PIH over the last
three and a half years this will be the
world-class Health Care Center moms and
kids deserve in Kono Hank it's
impossible to communicate the scale of
this place with a camera but Footers are
being poured Tresses are being welded
plumbing and wiring is going in and the
first words will hopefully open next
year I sought a dumbaya the nurse
Midwife who leads maternal Health at the
hospital is working closely with build
Health International engineer John Chu
and his team to make sure that
everything is right where it should be
John by the way has a phenomenal Sharpie
hat at the maternal Center of Excellence
there will not only be excellent
maternal care there will also be two
neonatal intensive care units one for
babies born in the hospital another for
babies born outside and brought to the
hospital as well as enough operating
theaters and supplies to perform up to
10 emergency C-sections every day and
the mcoe will also be a teaching
hospital so a new generation of midwives
nurses and doctors will train there we
also got to visit the site where the
dormitories and staff housing will be
and met some kids engaging in the
time-honored cross-cultural tradition of
young boys watching big machines but but
it's not only healthcare workers who are
learning and being trained via the mcoe
as John Chu explained to us almost all
the people working on the construction
site have been trained in new skills
partly via classes and partly via get
this educational YouTube videos we go to
YouTube University on the TV
65 of the construction workers on this
site are women and I got to chat with
three of them including Hawa who was
selling corn on the street in koidu
before getting this job and who now has
become an expert in reading blueprints
and trains new workers on how to use
tools
she told me about how profoundly her
life has changed but also about how she
feels differently about herself
they never see the construction women
before Marie has also been able to learn
a highly skilled trade
to when they now
and success after working as a Mason on
the site is now a steel binder she has a
theory on why so many women are working
at the mcoe we know that one day we'll
give back in this Hospital our children
will be coming here so that's why I will
try and all efforts to build this
hospital but to be clear I saw it and
her team aren't waiting on buildings to
improve maternal and child health more
nurses and doctors are already training
at the existing facilities more
community health workers are being hired
to identify high-risk pregnancies via
house call and most astonishingly a
special care baby unit at the hospital
has already dramatically reduced child
mortality the idea is that they should
always have access to their babies and
be able to to feed on-demand as needed
before we visited the unit I saw it
explained to us that as recently as two
years ago the vast majority of these
babies would have died the unit is full
so so full that at times the team has to
make unspeakably difficult decisions
about who they can admit but the babies
here receive excellent care world-class
care the kind of care that every baby
deserves there are many such special
care baby units at hospitals around
Sierra Leone but very few of them are
functioning because it's not just about
the building and supplying incubators
it's also about the staff the training
the ongoing supplies needed to run such
a unit maintenance and so much more
because I SATA and her team have not
just the building and the incubators but
also the support they need to succeed
this unit is thriving and so to the
thousands of you who donate monthly at
pih.org Hank and John and the thousands
more who've made one-time gifts to the
people who've brought attention by
sharing this project with friends and
family this is the change you're making
two years ago the parents of almost all
of these kids kids would have gone home
heartbroken but the kind of dignified
high quality health care that everyone
deserves is coming to Kono and with it
generational change to properly support
the mcoe and the larger strengthening of
kono's Health Care system over the next
few years we still need to raise the
paltry sum of uh just over 10 million
dollars so we have a long way to go if
you can join the monthly donors or make
a one-time gift check out pih.org Hank
and John and if you're considering
making a large gift we've had donations
from two thousand dollars to five
hundred thousand dollars please give via
the special link below or email me with
questions and if you can't afford to
donate that's okay thank you for your
attention it matters if I've learned
anything from the first three and a half
years of this project it is this
collectively we are much more likely to
solve the problems that we pay attention
to when we were in the special care baby
unit partners and health co-founder
Ophelia Dahl asked a nurse if one
especially frail baby on a CPAP machine
was likely to live
all these babies are going to live the
nurse responded this is the good news
room I'm so proud that koidu government
hospital now has a good Newsroom and
with the work of Marie Hawa success and
so many others on the maternal Center of
Excellence there is much more good news
to come Hank look at what humans can do
when we come together
I'll see you on Friday